uh what about this one what SCP
researcher called to the other you've
got to be kidding his colleague scoffed
interpreting the suggestion as little
more than a joke that thing's a piece of
junk she tapped a knuckle against the
glass case catching the attention of the
tiny figure inside oh dares exclaimed
the tinny monotone voice Release Me From
This irksome confinement so that I might
bring about your final undoing Vermin
for I Am doombah 2000 the ultimate
bringer of Destruction both researchers
laughed at the small automaton inside
the glass they had come to a CP item
Gallery 27 in search of non-organic
anomalies to gather for testing but
judging by their reactions it seemed
that scp-1370 wasn't going to make the
cut the Cobble together robot was widely
considered to be a harmless clumsy
little Oddity rather than any kind of
threat but that didn't stop as CP 1370
from challenging any and all things
around it to a battle to the death
battles it always lost ah this thing is
junk the second researcher remarked
flicking her finger at the glass again
in an attempt to startle the robot it is
not organic though the other pointed out
observing that scp-1370 had been
constructed out of various recycled
Parts its head was a defunct and
non-operational voltmeter soldered
awkwardly onto a weak neck joint its
arms were wrenches and it had been
configured in such a way that gave the
robot a top-heavy impractical design
inorganic yes but worth our time
definitely not come on we'll find
something else to test in scp-914 as the
pair of researchers turned their backs
on scp-1370 it began to squawk at them
again through the speaker embedded in
its chest you dare walk away from me you
have wrinkered the Wrath of robo-lord
the destructor and will soon be reduced
to atoms by my hand the tiny junk robot
charged towards the two Foundation
personnel only to slam front first into
the glass of the display case it was
kept contained in the force of the
impact combined with scp-1370s imbalance
design caused it to topple over and land
on its back leaving a huge crack in the
glass ah great one of the researchers
side rolling her eyes we're gonna have
to report that
scp-1370s damaged its case again come on
let's go and get someone to replace that
glass you think we should just leave it
here unsupervised in a damaged case the
other ask look at the thing it's hardly
competent enough to escape the fellow
researcher replied as the tiny robot
struggled to get itself back upright I'm
sure it'll be fine for a few minutes
little did the pair of researchers
realize as they left item Gallery 27
that scp-1370 had been listening to
their conversation picking up on a few
details while the anomalous automaton
often displayed a low level of
intelligence and awareness of its
surroundings it was still self-aware and
on top of that harbored a hatred for all
things it believed to be living although
it could be easily tricked and lacked
any kind of real fighting ability but it
had picked up on something the
researchers had mentioned an
scp-914 perhaps through its own limited
intelligence or some kind of other
anomalous awareness the tiny robot
detected this to mean another machine
and so standing back up it struck the
glass of its display case again
shattering one side completely it hopped
down to the ground tumbling over thanks
to its lack of balance only to
eventually stand back up and start
making its way through the facility
being only a meter tall made it easy for
scp-1370 otherwise known as pesterbot to
sneak through the corridors of the
foundation site undetected it eventually
arrived at a room housing a large mass
of gears and Gyros a machine filled with
Clockwork components that seemed to pull
the little robot further in as it drew
closer and closer to what the
researchers had spoken of
scp-914 the Clockworks a device that
could be used to refine any object
placed inside it depending on the
setting items could be transformed
destroyed or vastly improved using the
Clockworks rough setting disintegrated
any test subject while coarse dismantled
it to its base components one to one
replaced any item with an almost
identical copy then the fine setting
would cause scp-914 to improve any item
and very fine could refine an object to
an even greater degree usually by
granting it anomalous properties testing
of all biological matter within scp-914
was strictly prohibited but pesterbot
well he was made of metal sneaking into
the room where the Clockworks was
located
scp-1370 immediately caught sight of
another Foundation researcher who had
been busy overseeing tests using the
very fine setting of scp-914 instantly
the agitated Little Robot made a beeline
for the researcher swiping at her ankles
with its wrench hands die die intrigued
power before the might of my claws none
can stand before the Relentless
destruction brought forth by shivatron
to spoiler of Mirth referring to itself
with one of its many elaborate
self-appointed titles caught by surprise
at the tiny robot the researcher turned
and screamed and surprised instinctively
she swung her leg back and brought it
Forward delivering a swift kick to
scp-1370 that sent its metal body
hurtling through the air right into the
Clockworks pesterbot landed inside the
input Booth the enormous collection of
clockwork components whirring and
heaving as they sprung to life the
researcher hadn't even realized what was
happening she'd been addressing how much
her foot hurt after kicking the small
metal robot by the time she looked up
scp-914 had already fully activated with
scp-1370 inside in horror she sounded
the alarm to summon security with no
idea what the very fine setting would do
to improve pesterbot a team of guards
filed into the room drawing their
weapons and training them on the output
Booth of the Clockworks while they
normally would have nothing to fear from
scp-1370 given its inability to ever win
in a fight that it started even when
fighting a potted plant that had been
affixed with a speaker the tiny robot
had been bested but the clockwork's
refinement process meant that what would
be stepping out of the machine wouldn't
be the pesterbot the foundation was
familiar with sure enough the heavy foot
that came stomping down on the facility
floor was a far cry from the flimsy
metal limbs
scp-1370 had previously had out of the
Clockworks emerged a hulking robotic
form not just bigger and bulkier than
the meter tall clumsy assembled
pesterbot but a huge Sleek machine built
for Bear it was more humanoid but stood
at nearly seven feet tall the weight and
balance issues that had plagued the
previous design were seemingly gone as
despite its increased size this new and
improved model of scp-1370 seemed to
move fluidly with smooth electronic
motions the robot turned and assessed
its surroundings scanning the group of
foundation security that had amassed
outside
scp-914 its first new targets as the
machine stepped towards them the
security Commander gave the word and the
guards opened fire a hail of gunfire
rang out deafening shots ringing in the
security officer's ears as bullets spat
out of their weapons towards the newly
refined pesterbot by the time each of
them had emptied their magazines and the
smoke cleared they realized to their
Terror that the robot was now
bulletproof you have engaged in an act
of violence against Doom Master 1370
master of all do it announced in a new
voice one far deeper and more imposing
than its previous tinny Candor now it
was a modulated electronic sound far
befitting its new look prepare to face
consequences
retaliating with that the robot leaped
into battle with all the grace and
ferocity of a wild cat the nearest
security guard barely had a chance to
reload his weapon raising his hands in a
weak attempt at a block before the
strike from a metallic fist knocked the
wind out of him moving with balletic
speed and precision pesterbot swiped and
shot at the guard each hit connecting
painfully with one of the man's vital
pressure points like it was a highly
trained hand-to-hand fighter when the
officer collapsed unable to move save
for letting out screams of excruciating
pain the robot turned to face its
remaining targets freeze one of the
foundation's security yelled raising his
pistol was shaking hands zipping
forwards scp-1370 grabbed the gun and
wrenched it from the man's fingers
tearing the weapon apart like it was
made of cardboard ripping the man by his
SCP Foundation uniform it launched him
directly upwards sending his body
crashing through the ceiling leaving a
human-shaped hole above chunks of
building materials rained down on the
robot including wiring and internal
lengths of cable that ran through the
walls and ceiling that were now exposed
as the security team retreated
scp-1370 curiously reached up and
gripped one of the electric cable holes
wrenching it out of the ceiling to
examine it closer causing Sparks to
shower pesterbot's new Sleek metallic
skin seemed to react to the metal in the
wiring drawing out the copper that
channeled electricity throughout the
foundation facility it was more than a
force of magnetism it was something else
ideas
scp-1370 was learning adapting and most
frightening of all coming up with new
ways to complete its purpose marching up
to the nearest wall it pulled back in
metal Fist and sent it slamming through
paintwork and plaster to draw out the
metal running through the building
outside in the corridor the lights died
in fact the entire facility lost its
power and plunged Into Darkness until
the backup emergency lights activated
filling the foundation's corridors with
low-level blood red light more security
officers had mobilized outside of the
Clockworks room expecting at any moment
that the refined version of the
previously harmless testerbot would soon
appear sure enough it did and the red
lighting was soon added to by yet
another hail of frightening gunfire but
now it seemed
scp-1370 had learned how to shoot back
an arc of lightning Zapped through the
corridor electrifying every guard it
touched and reducing them to little more
than a smoldering husk a second one
followed striking one guard with a bolt
of blue electricity that then leaked
from his body to the officer standing
next to him who had been close enough to
touch his Fallen comrade and it was of
course wearing plenty of conductive
metal the wiring in the walls the
electricity
scp-1370 had learned how to weaponize it
and that wasn't all as the robot stepped
out of the room it had pulled various
other metalwork from the fabric of the
building around it into its form adding
to its body in new and gruesome ways its
shoulders now had additional armor long
poles of rebar now extended out of its
robotic forearms to act as crude
rudimentary impaling weapons it had
gotten even taller and all forged out of
metal it harvested from its surroundings
scp-1370 hadn't just been made a better
fighter it had given something else by
scp-914
intelligence the capacity for it to
learn and perpetually adapt itself and
it wouldn't stop it would keep improving
itself to enact its original purpose to
fight anything and everything around it
a Slaughter ensued everything the SCP
Foundation threw at this new version of
the pesterbot only gave it more weapons
and more offensive capabilities to add
to its growing Arsenal the rebar weapons
and its arms were replaced with Sleek
sharp blades even bullets fired at it
seemed to be absorbed into its mass
allowing it to keep growing
scp-1370 was Unstoppable obliterating
everyone that came to desperately try to
contain it and as it bested every
opponent left them decimated and
defeated something new happened to the
robot it couldn't feel emotions just
like with any automaton it lacked the
level of human cognition and complexity
to respond to things with fear
but as it killed more and more
Foundation staff left and right
annihilating everything in its path
scp-1370 experience something not an
emotion but whatever the closest robotic
equivalent to Pure unbridled happiness
was satisfaction of the machine now able
to complete the function it was
originally built for yet had failed that
for so long getting bigger and bigger
adapting and adding more machines to
itself eventually
scp-1370 was a hulking Behemoth cars and
their combustion engines all became part
of the robotic giant every new piece of
technology it encountered becoming a
deadly weapon and as pesterbot started
to Tower over buildings a huge scale
robotic threat the foundation had no
choice it was time to deploy another big
bad bot to cut
scp-1370 back down to size it was time
to send in the dragon slayer now go
check out what if scp-096 was put inside
scp-914 where the shy guys were fined
into well you'll have to click and see
and scp-914 what did you put in it to
see what happened when we opened up the
Clockworks to you the fans